les amis dans cette vidéo je vais
répondre un maximum de vos questions sur
les coulisses de la chaîne de Hugo
descript etc et je vais aussi donc vous
présenter et bien les studios et le
bureau on travaille au quotidien avec
mon équipe c'est passé beaucoup de
choses cette année plein de nouveaux
formats plein d'interviews la
présidentielle on a testé des choses ont
toujours et ça me semblait sympa on
s'est fin d'année de vous présenter un
petit peu comment est-ce qu'on travaille
au quotidien et à quoi ça ressemble ici
du coup bienvenue je vais vous faire une
présentation et on commence tout de
suite on va aller dans mon bureau où je
tourne au quotidien les actus du jour
tous les formats qu'on fait sur TikTok
les formats qu'on fait sur Youtube comme
ça vous allez pouvoir découvrir tout ça
ce que vous voyez ici c'est en fait ce
qu'on appelle l'open space enfin c'est
le l'espace de travail les bureaux qu'on
a ici c'est 250 m² de bureau où il y a à
la fois l'endroit où l'équipe travaille
au quotidien il y a à la fois en espace
plus détente et cuisine etc où les gens
peuvent se poser à midi le soir ou autre
et il y a aussi un dernier endroit qui
est le studio de tournage on fait
quasiment tout au formats aujourd'hui et
ça je vous le montrer en fin de vidéo
alors première espace que je voulais
vous montrer c'est le studio où je
tourne en fait la plupart des actus du
jour sur Youtube ou alors sur Tik Tok ou
même en podcast c'est aussi ici que
l'équipe d'ailleurs peut tourner soit
les actualités en bref soit certains Tik
Tok quand il le font au quotidien c'est
un bureau assez classique d'ailleurs là
vous allez le voir ici il y a plein de
petits souvenirs de tournage de choses
qu'on a pu faire je donne quelques
exemples qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir ici
un vinyle de Stromae qu'on a eu la
chance d'interviewer cette année sur la
chaîne c'était il y a quelques mois on a
un jeu vidéo le flambeau alors ça c'est
collector c'est aussi complètement fake
parce que évidemment c'est pas un vrai
CD mais on avait reçu Jonathan Cohen
aussi dans mashup on va en reparler tout
à l'heure mais j'ai eu l'occasion
d'interviewer quelques mois c'était très
très cool il y a aussi pas mal de livres
je vais pas vous mentir qu'on reçoit de
la part d'éditeur ou autre donc des
livres aussi parfois politiques etc etc
oh il y a aussi des choses sympathiques
qui sont passées cette année on a eu
droit à un article dont le New York
Times voilà ça je vais juste trop
plaisir c'est en juin en France les
youtubeurs sont nouveaux visages de
l'information politique ça fait quand
même très plaisir je vais pas vous
mentir c'était assez grosse
reconnaissance pour le travail qu'on
fait avec toute l'équipe aujourd'hui
donc c'était très cool d'avoir ce petit
article dans le New York Times et donc
c'est là que je tourne les actus du jour
au quotidien le fonctionnement est très
simple en fait ici j'ai un fond vert que
je peux monter ça vous connaissez je
pense que la plupart des streamers ou
des youtubeurs l'utilisent aujourd'hui
quand ils tournent en fond vert et donc
face à moi c'est assez simple je tourne
avec le micro qui est juste là et le PC
qui est juste ici il y a beaucoup de
questions sur la tablette où est passé
finalement l'iPad ces derniers mois
c'est très simple jusqu'ici je tournais
du coup avec la l'iPad dans les mains et
j'avais mes notes et ça me permettait de
tourner comme ça je l'ai fait pendant
quelques temps l'iPad il est présent
mais il est présent ici et en fait il
fait office de prompteur ce qui me
permet en fait une fois que moi j'ai
validé à ce que je voulais dire et les
différentes actus etc ça me permet de
mettre directement sur le prompteur et
c'est plus simple pour moi pour tourner
au quotidien alors cette FAQ est
extrêmement bien préparée c'est à dire
qu'en plus de la vie des bureaux j'ai
essayé de décomposer les questions que
vous m'avez envoyées sur Instagram ont
trois temps d'abord des questions un peu
perso ensuite des questions liées à
l'organisation avec toute l'équipe
aujourd'hui et enfin des questions liées
à l'avenir et ce qui arrive sur la
chaîne dans les prochains jours donc je
commence avec les questions un peu plus
perso depuis quand aimes-tu faire du
journalisme ça fait très longtemps que
j'ai un intérêt pour le journaliste mais
pour tout ça je sais pas exactement à
quoi c'est dû mais j'avais eu l'occasion
de poster vous l'avez sûrement vu sur
Instagram des photos de moi 7-8 ans en
train de déjà soit présenter une sorte
de JT que je faisais avec mon frère
bonjour et bienvenue à ce journal on va
tout de suite démarrer avec des faits
divers alors ça monte Haute-Normandie à
vous ma [ __ ] soit éditer un journal que
j'imprimais que je distribuais dans la
rue donc c'est beaucoup de choses liées
aux journalistes que je fais depuis
quelques temps maintenant de là à dire
que depuis que je suis petit je vais
être journaliste je pense pas tout
simplement je trouve ça marron de le
faire et avec le recul c'est vrai que
oui ça faisait quelques temps que je
fais ça dès le collège écrit l'ancien
site internet où j'écrivais des articles
sur le sport puis il y a eu le lancement
d'un autre site que j'ai fait avec
d'autres jeunes qui s'appelait Radio
Londres qui étaient là aussi une autre
façon pour moi d'écrire des articles et
de de m'essayer à tout ça jusqu'à du
coup le lancement du God écrite en 2015
quand je venais de commencer mes études
à Sciences Po autre question vu que tu
regardes tout le temps les actus et ce
que tu es pas un peu angoissé évidemment
l'actualité ça peut être une source
d'angoisse et ça l'est d'ailleurs pour
beaucoup de gens c'est ce qui fait que
on essaie de mettre le plus possible des
bonnes nouvelles ou autre quand on a
pour pas savoir que des éléments qui
sont anxiogènes ou des mauvaises
nouvelles en général dans l'actualité
maintenant c'est vrai que quand on
travaille sur ces sujets là on y est
confronté au quotidien maintenant je
pense que les émotions dans le
journalisme c'est une sorte d'équilibre
à avoir c'est à dire que il faut pas
être complètement froid et pas être
sensible à ce qui se fait parce que ça
n'aurait juste pas de sens mais en même
temps il faut pas se retrouver
complètement absorbé par ses émotions au
point de pas avoir une forme de recul
qui peut être nécessaire dans certains
cas pour bien faire son travail autre
question tu te considères plus comme un
youtubeur ou comme un journaliste c'est
une question qui revient souvent surtout
d'autres médias aux journalistes qui
posent la question en général je me suis
considère plus comme journaliste parce
que ça englobe en fait tout ce que je
fais avec mon équipe au quotidien sur
les réseaux sociaux maintenant le terme
de youtubeur je suis pas forcément
contre c'est à dire que moi-même pendant
longtemps je me suis défini comme
youtuber et je lance je me sentais pas
légitime disons à me définir comme
journaliste j'ai commencé sur Youtube
c'est encore là on est énormément suivi
aujourd'hui ce qui est peut-être un peu
bizarre par contre avec le terme de
youtubeurs aujourd'hui c'est que
forcément on est sur plein d'autres
réseaux sociaux en même temps donc si je
suis youtubeur je suis aussi instagramer
Tic-Toc twitcher ça se dit pas mais
streamer quoi et ça a pas forcément de
sens de se définir aussi par une
plateforme c'est un peu un peu bizarre
autrement les deux termes me vont
aujourd'hui bon après il y avait
énormément de questions sur la question
de l'équilibre vie Provis perso combien
que je travaillais par semaine etc etc
et je tenais à répondre à cette question
non pas pour être en mode à regarder je
bosse énormément attendez c'est pour ça
que j'ai réussi aujourd'hui et que
maintenant ma chaîne fonctionne pas du
tout c'est pas du tout l'objectif au
contraire je trouve que sur les réseaux
sociaux il y a beaucoup de choses qui
viennent valoriser le fait de travailler
énormément et quand je dis énormément
c'est le côté vraiment se tuer au
travail littéralement en fait bah ça me
semble pas forcément pertinent quoi être
valorisé ça en gros ce que je veux dire
ici c'est que selon moi il faut pas
valoriser le fait de se tuer au travail
justement et ne pas compter les heures
au travail il y a des gens pour qui ça
fonctionne il y a des gens pour qui ça
fonctionne pas le tout c'est de savoir
s'écouter et je dis ça aussi du coup
pour vous alors si vous êtes étudiant ou
même salarié c'est des choses qui sont
pas forcément faciles à appliquer parce
que parfois vous avez des horaires et
c'est très dur de sortir de ça ou
réellement appliquer ce que je veux dire
là mais ça me semble absolument
essentiel de pouvoir s'écouter et je
voulais juste voilà dire ça oui je
travaille énormément encore aujourd'hui
sur la chaîne mais c'est pas pour autant
que tout le monde doit faire ça ou c'est
quelque chose de parfait il faut trouver
tout simplement le bon équilibre par
rapport à notre situation alors nous
voici dans les bureaux c'est ici du coup
que toute l'équipe travaille au
quotidien là en l'occurrence on est un
vendredi 23 décembre dans l'après-midi
autant vous dire que entre les gens
malades les gens ont congé les gens en
télétravail bref il y a pas grand monde
et pour vous expliquer du coup comment
ça s'organise en fait on a trois pôles
aujourd'hui au sein de l'équipe on a
toute l'équipe de journalistes qui est
évidemment la majorité de l'équipe et
qui travaille sur tous les formats qu'on
fait aujourd'hui les actus du jour les
formations TikTok les reportages bref
les interviews ou autre on a tout un peu
aussi lié à la production et qui
travaille sur le montage la post prod
les tournages et tout ce qu'on fait là
dessus et enfin on a toute l'équipe plus
commerciale qui travaille sur la
question des partenariats sur les
invitations les collaborations qu'on
peut faire ou autre et donc c'est comme
ça qu'on s'organise en trois pôles
différents sachant que on était il y a
un an et demi je pense 4-5 au sein de
l'équipe donc ça a vraiment vraiment
grandi en un an et demi je vais vous en
parler juste après mais c'est qui fait
du coup qui nous a il a fallu qu'on ait
des bureaux comme ça assez grand
aujourd'hui pour accueillir tout le
monde et aujourd'hui c'est une sorte de
de rédaction finalement qu'on peut avoir
au quotidien avec toute l'équipe et
forcément c'est assez sympa d'avoir tout
le monde dit à l'entrée petit mur
végétal avec un petit néon Hugo décrypte
écoutez ça fait plaisir et surtout on a
été accompagné par Greenwood que je
remercie beaucoup qui nous a simplement
mis en place ce mur végétal parce que
c'est un vrai mur végétal sont poursuit
la visite ici on a une salle de réunion
ma foi pas très intéressante donc je
vais pas vous le montrer on s'en fout un
peu ici par contre c'est l'espace un peu
plus détente on va dire où l'équipe en
fait peut se poser soit pour travailler
soit pour déjeuner soit pour faire une
partie de FIFA ou de Mario Kart s'ils
veulent sur la télé c'est un endroit un
peu plus détente avec du coup notamment
la cuisine ici alors avant de vous
présenter le studio qui est juste là bas
on fait pas mal de tournage et répondre
aussi à d'autres questions là-bas je
vais prendre quelques questions ici la
une question d'ailleurs qui est beaucoup
revenue sur Instagram penses-tu encore
recruter à l'avenir alors je l'ai dit là
l'équipe a beaucoup grandi sur la
dernière année et demi on est passé de
4-5 à 19 personnes au sein de l'équipe
il y a des recrutements qui vont
sûrement arriver ce que je peux vous
conseiller si vous voulez nous rejoindre
d'une façon d'une autre quel que soit
votre profil votre rôle ou quoi c'est de
nous envoyer un mail à candidature avec
un S at Hugo décrypte.com dans le mail
mettez ce que vous voulez dites nous ce
que vous pensez pouvoir apporter dans
quel cadre dites-nous tout ça comme ça
ça nous permettra de regarder et on
reçoit régulièrement en fait des
candidatures spontanées et parfois du
coup des gens rejoignent l'équipe
simplement parce qu'un jour ils ont
envoyé comme c'est une bouteille à la
mer en disant je sais pas je vais vous
recruter mais c'est un jour vous
recrutez moi ça m'intéresse c'est le cas
de vanon d'ailleurs qui est de l'autre
côté de la caméra vraiment n'hésitez pas
à nous envoyer un mail pensez juste à
être les plus précis entre guillemets
possible sur ce que vous recherchez ce
que c'est un stage est-ce que c'est un
CDI est-ce que c'est en freelance à quel
rythme à quelle période etc ça nous
permet comme ça de faire un premier
check là-dessus et l'autre question
d'ailleurs qui est liée souvent à tout
ça à l'équipe ou autre c'est la question
du modèle économique comment est-ce
qu'on s'en sort aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
et quelle est notre modèle économique en
fait aujourd'hui il y a deux éléments il
y a à la fois la monétisation des vidéos
et à la fois tout simplement des
partenariats qu'on peut faire donc la
monétisation des vidéos c'est ce qu'on
peut avoir sur Youtube ce qu'on peut
avoir aussi en podcast sur plusieurs
plateformes c'est les pubs qui vont
s'afficher avant de voir la vidéo la
chance qu'on a de notre côté c'est qu'on
produit beaucoup et avec un rythme quand
même qui est assez important donc mine
de rien c'est rentrer d'argent qui est
très important pour nous et qui nous
permet quand même de payer une bonne
partie de l'équipe en plus de ça on a
donc des partenariats qu'on peut
développer que ce soit avec des marques
que ce soit avec des institutions ou
autre pour créer du coup et bien un
contenu sponsorisé sur nos réseaux
sociaux que ce soit sur Instagram
YouTube Tik Tok quel que soit le réseau
social et on fait bien attention le plus
attention possible avec mon équipe dans
le choix de ses partenaires à pas
travailler avec n'importe qui on refuse
quand même une très grande partie des
partenariats qu'on nous propose parce
qu'en fait il faut trouver un alignement
en terme de valeur en termes de sujet
pour que vraiment on puisse bosser avec
une marque ou autre et donc avec ses
partenaires avec qui on décide de
travailler on va créer un contenu sur
nos réseaux ça peut être sur Instagram
ou autre sachant qu'à chaque fois
syndiquait très clairement que c'est un
partenariat alors dans notre cas
aujourd'hui la chaîne marche très très
bien donc on est très sollicité et donc
on a la chance ce luxe de pouvoir
refuser des partenariats et accepter ce
qui nous semble cohérent maintenant on
essaie de pas reposer uniquement sur les
partenariats et la monétisation donc
pour tout vous dire on travaille en ce
moment sur d'autres choses qu'on peut
développer au-delà du côté cryptes je
vous en reparlerai on peut passer à la
suite de la visite dernière partie de
cet faq/pre présentation de bureau je
vais vous montrer du coup ce qui se
cache derrière là en fait ici c'est le
studio de tournage dès qu'on a vu ces
bureaux là on les a trouvé super
intéressants parce qu'en fait il y avait
à la fois un espace qui pouvait être un
peu nos bureaux à la fois un espace plus
détente ici et ici un studio de tournage
qu'on allait pouvoir aménager sachant
que faut bien se dire que avant et bien
il y avait absolument rien ici c'était
vraiment de la moquette ici même pas
c'est cloisons là on a tout fait
installer pour en faire du coup un
studio en l'espace de quelques semaines
je vous montre du coup à quoi ça
ressemble à l'intérieur au passage vous
le voyez ici quelques-unes de personnes
qui sont passées au bureau certaines
interviews qui sont ici notamment Bill
Gates voilà qui est venu donc dans cette
vidéo et dans ce studio là pour faire
l'interview il y a quelques semaines
encore aujourd'hui je trouve ça
improbable au possible de de l'avoir
comme ça devant le logo HUGO décrypse
juste ici ça n'a aucun sens mais donc à
quoi ça ressemble à l'intérieur vous
allez le voir on va découvrir le studio
et commençons par la Régie qui est donc
présente juste ici d'une régie qu'on a
voulu équiper au maximum pour pouvoir
tout faire des formats en live des
formats ont froid toutes sortes de
choses d'ailleurs c'est le cas aussi du
plateau à côté tout est fait pour faire
toutes sortes de formats mais pour ça du
coup il nous fallait du matériel de
qualité bon je vais pas rentrer dans
tous les détails techniques parce que
c'est pas une vidéo faite pour ça mais
pour que vous compreniez bien comment ça
marche quand on fait une émission en
live par exemple il y a plusieurs postes
là en général c'est le poste de la
personne qui est sur la Real donc c'est
lui qui choisit ce qui est affiché
finalement à l'écran et il est donc ici
on a quelqu'un aussi ici qui se met sur
la prod et qui bosse sur pas mal
d'éléments différents il va annoncer
certaines choses et les envoyer au Real
ou autre on a ici une place pour
quelqu'un sur l'édito donc si
typiquement là quand j'avais une
interviewé Bill Gates j'avais une
oreillette au cas où pour avoir un
retour de mon équipe de journalistes sur
le temps qui me restait surtout ça et
bien donc ils peuvent se poser ici on a
quelqu'un évidemment sur le son et enfin
là on a des éléments pour la lumière ou
autre parce que vous allez le voir tout
est modulable à côté pour avoir des
ambiances et des rendus différents et au
passage un très très grand merci à LDLC
c'est LDLC qui en fait tout simplement
nous a équipé notamment avec les
ordinateurs que vous apercevez ici qui
nous permettent de faire ces contenus au
quotidien merci du fond du cœur pour
leur confiance et pour ce matériel qui
nous permet de faire tout ça au
quotidien ça fait super plaisir alors je
vais reprendre quelques questions mais
avant ça du coup découvrez un petit peu
le studio de tournage on fait quasiment
tous nos formats au quotidien le voici
pour moi c'est forcément super stimulant
se dire qu'on a un espace comme ça au
cœur de Paris pour faire ce qu'on veut
je vous montre donc à quoi ça ressemble
vous le voyez il y a des lumières tout
le long l'avantage d'avoir des lumières
comme ça tout autour et encore il y en a
d'autres qui arrivent je crois bientôt
c'est que en fait c'est complètement
modulable et on peut faire ce qu'on veut
à différents endroits si je veux faire
un face caméra une interview posé ici on
peut organiser les lumières pour que ce
soit le cas si je veux faire un format
de plateau ou d'interviews comme c'est
le cas ici on peut le faire en fait ce
studio on a essayé de le penser comme un
mélange le plus pertinent possible entre
à la fois des choses qui viennent du web
et à la fois des choses qui viennent de
format plus traditionnel disons que ce
soit la télévision ou encore le cinéma
concrètement comment on a fait on a eu
par exemple gosulting qui nous a
accompagné qui a fait un gros gros
travail ici pour mettre en place la
régie pas mal d'équipements ou autre ils
ont cette expérience là en fait pour
nous accompagner sur la mise en place du
studio et en même temps surtout le côté
décor on a fait appel à Juliette Mezel
que qui a fait un énorme travail ici
elle est allée chercher pour tous vous
dire là-bas pas mal d'éléments que ce
soit de l'ordre de brocantes que ce soit
à plein d'endroits différents pour avoir
comme ça cette atmosphère là et Juliette
elle a l'habitude de faire des choses
soit pour le ciné soit pour la
télévision de mettre en place du coup
des beaux vrais décors et donc ça nous a
permis d'avoir ce studio là qui mêle un
peu ces deux compétences et je suis
honnêtement ultra ultra content durant
et d'ailleurs du coup pour tous ceux qui
se demandent c'est vrai que c'est ici
qu'on a fait notamment mashup chaque
mercredi pendant un an si une émission
qu'on a décidé de stopper et de mettre
en pause pour le moment alors moi
j'adorais faire cette émission là c'est
à dire que l'idée d'avoir une émission
chaque semaine comme ça sur twitch et
après sur Youtube et en podcast je
voyais que ça plaisait et je sentais que
c'était quelque chose qui était
intéressant à faire mais en même temps
en fait il y avait 36000 formats qu'on
voulait faire en parallèle et notamment
le format d'interview face cachée que
vous avez beaucoup vu ces derniers mois
avec
Omar Sy Angel enfin bref pas mal de
on a été au Bill Gates qui sont venus et
ça fait partie de ces formats qu'on a
aussi voulu pousser on pousse aussi
beaucoup en ce moment vous le voyez des
vidéos sur la chaîne principale sur
Youtube des grosses vidéos sur certains
sujets il y a aussi des reportages qui
arrivent tout ça pour dire que il a
fallu faire un choix sur les formats
qu'on voulait faire et j'avais pas
forcément un temps illimité et donc on a
décidé de mettre en pause mashup pour le
moment pour pouvoir se concentrer sur
ces autres formats et au passage là
dessus je tiens à remercier vraiment
Julien qui a énormément travaillé sur la
mise en place avec Clément de ce studio
là ça a été un gros rush parce que en
fait il y avait des retards sur les
travaux à un moment en parallèle il y
avait les missions mashup qu'on devait
lancer donc tout est arrivé un peu au
même moment et c'était très dur à gérer
et franchement ils ont géré ça de façon
extrêmement forte et ça nous a permis du
coup d'avoir celui là bon je vais
prendre les toutes dernières questions
sur l'avenir de la chaîne et les projets
qui viennent une question aussi
rapidement comment les médias
traditionnels vous voient-il c'est une
question intéressante je pense que ça a
beaucoup évolué au fil du temps au début
c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup médias il y
avait une forme de mépris en bref il
faut le dire ou de la part de certains
journalistes vis-à-vis de ce qu'on
faisait sur le côté en fait si vous
faites du journalisme sur Youtube c'est
pas du journalisme ou alors vous êtes
encore étudiant ou jeune ça fonctionne
pas ça n'a pas de sens ou autre et
aujourd'hui alors qu'au fondamentalement
on n'a pas changé notre travail
simplement on est une équipe assez
nombreuse je vois que le regard a changé
et que c'est plus forcément les mêmes
retours qu'on peut avoir je pense que ça
vient surtout avec l'audience c'est à
dire qu'en fait le fait qu'on soit
autant suivi aujourd'hui qu'on soit
enfin mine de rien le podcast le plus
écouté en France le compte
d'informations le plus suivis sur TikTok
sur Youtube aussi je pense le fait pour
dire les choses que chaque jour
aujourd'hui on informe littéralement des
millions de personnes bah je pense que
ça a changé clairement le regard que les
médias plus traditionnels peuvent avoir
sur nous après je pense que ce regard
c'est pas forcément du mépris parfois
c'est juste un manque de connaissances
de ce qu'on peut faire c'est à dire que
si tu connais pas ce qu'on fait et que
tu es pas par exemple sur TikTok bah oui
au moment de parler d'informations sur
Tik Tok
que tu vas pas forcément réalisé que bah
oui Tik Tok peut être une plateforme
d'information que enfin là dans notre
cas on a fait plus d'un milliard de vues
en un an sur TikTok un milliard de vues
ça n'a juste aucun sens et voilà c'est
des choses je pense qu'il faut expliquer
et faire comprendre que dans le cas
précis là par exemple de Tik Tok c'est
pas juste une plateforme de
divertissement quoi autre question
est-ce que tu comptes faire des concepts
qui sont moins de l'information mais par
exemple humour ou challenge
non c'est pas prévu c'est à dire que
vous verrez pas sur la chaîne dans les
prochains jours d'un coup en fitness fun
je sais pas quoi avec un autre youtuber
sur Hugo décryp ça c'est pas prévu pour
autant oui vous l'avez vu ça m'est
arrivé de faire pas mal de vidéos sur
les chaînes d'amis alors je pense
surtout à Squeezie et que tu en as fait
quand même pas mal sur sa chaîne Youtube
du coup et en vrai je pense pas que ce
soit gênant de le faire c'est à dire
qu'en fait je pense que vous faites la
part des choses quand vous me voyez
éventuellement sur la chaîne de Squeezie
par exemple ou quand vous me voyez ici
en train de présenter les actus vous
voyez déjà que le ton est pas du tout le
même entre les deux chaînes et c'est
bien normal donc non pas de vidéo des
style prévu sur Hugo descript mais par
contre sur d'autres chaînes clairement
il y en aura d'autres parce que ça me
fait bien kiffer on se marre bien à le
faire donc il y en a d'autres qui
peuvent être eu dernière question pour
que cette FAQ ne dure pas trois heures
que comptes-tu faire comme format déjà
vous l'avez peut-être vu sur notre
chaîne YouTube principale on s'est mis à
faire quasiment un format un rythme
pardon d'une vidéo par semaine ce qui
est ce qu'on n'a pas fait depuis
extrêmement longtemps et c'est des
vidéos vous le voyez là aussi qui
prennent du temps à produire parce que
soit c'est des formats longs sur des
sujets historiques donc c'est 20-30
minutes sur un sujet et c'est beaucoup
de temps de préparation d'écriture avec
l'équipe de montage de motion design ou
autre soit c'est des formats
d'interviews et là je pense que j'aurai
l'occasion d'en reparler un jour mais
c'est derrière semaine on s'est mis à
faire des formats d'interview de plus en
plus produits avec en fait beaucoup de
moyens qui sont mis en prod et forcément
là aussi c'est tout un travail derrière
et des moyens qui sont engagés et quand
on fait une interview d'Angèle au milieu
d'un Zénith forcément il y a beaucoup de
travail de production derrière donc en
fait de plus en plus de vidéos de ce
type là et je veux qu'on continue à
avoir ce rythme d'une vidéo par semaine
en parallèle à ça en fait il y a pas mal
d'autres projets autour du godetrips
qu'on est en train de développer je vais
être très chiant parce que je vais pas
vous spoiler et vous détailler ni même
vous tisez quoi que ce soit enfin si je
suis un peu en train de le faire du coup
mais en gros il y a plein de choses sur
lequel on travaille au-delà du haut des
cryptes des choses qui sont signées sur
lequel on avance d'autres choses qui
sont en cours de réflexion mais qui
pourraient venir prochainement bref
plein de belles choses qui arrivent dans
plein de domaines différents j'ai très
très hâte de vous en parler bon écoutez
je crois que j'ai trop parlé dans cet
FAQ mais ça me semblait un peu
intéressant de répondre comme ça à vos
questions et aussi de faire en sorte de
vous montrer un peu où est-ce qu'on
travaille au quotidien tiens juste quand
même pour terminer à vous remercier
vraiment du fond du coeur pour votre
confiance je sais que je dis ça en
permanence mais je le pense réellement
c'est à dire que je n’étais pas c'était
pas évident finalement lançant la chaîne
il y a quelques années qu'on se
retrouverait aujourd'hui avec une équipe
à faire ce travail là pour autant de
personnes parce que vous êtes quand même
extrêmement nombreux aujourd'hui à
suivre la chaîne je m'y attendais pas
forcément au début évidemment je l'avais
dans un coin de ma tête mais l'idée que
ça prenne cette ampleur là ça clairement
je pouvais pas le soupçonner et pour moi
j'ai la chance de faire un métier que
j'ai toujours voulu faire d'avoir une
grande liberté sur le choix des sujets
sur la façon de les approcher cette
forme d'indépendance en fait elle me
tient à cœur et donc je suis super
content d'être dans ce cadre-là et de
pouvoir vous proposer aussi ce qu'on
fait au quotidien merci du coup pour
tout ça merci aussi pour vos retours qui
nous aident à nous améliorer j'en ai
peut-être pas assez parlé aujourd'hui
mais vos commentaires que ce soit sur
Youtube que ce soit sur Tik Tok enfin
bref sur tous les réseaux insta ou autre
au quotidien il nous aide beaucoup c'est
à dire qu'on est toujours vigilant à ce
que vous nous dites et ça nous permet
aussi de voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut
améliorer au quotidien sur le fond sur
la forme sur tout ça bref merci du fond
du coeur si vous n'êtes pas encore
abonné bah c'est bizarre parce que du
coup vous êtes allé jusqu'au bout d'une
vidéo FAQ sur une chaîne que vous ne
suivez pas du coup pour ça vous abonner
pour ne pas louper les vidéos suivantes
vous avez aussi du coup la chaîne des
actus du jour sur laquelle on poste pas
mal de choses notamment une vidéo du
lundi au vendredi je vous mets la chaîne
directement en description je le redis
au passage parce que vous êtes de plus
en très nombreux mais certains ne sont
pas au courant ce format des actus du
jour qu'on fait du lundi au vendredi il
est aussi dispo en podcast et vous êtes
d’ailleurs avec nous le podcast le plus
écouté en France sur ce format des
actifs du jour ça n'a aucun sens donc
vraiment merci merci du fond du cœur
voilà je suis un peu crevé je dois aller
tourner en plus des actus du jour juste
après je vais du coup y aller merci pour
tout prenez soin de vous prenez soin de
vos proches et puis on se dit à très
vite pour une nouvelle vidéo